no no no no no no no
no
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by salma hayek pineau
she's an academy award-nominated actress
and film producer who for decades has
been a hollywood icon and leading box
office draw from desperado to frida the
hitman's wife's bodyguard and many more
her latest though is the highly
anticipated marvel studios release
eternals which is set to theaters on
november 5th salma hayek welcome to the
show thank you very excited to be here
and then i know that you're a fan of
valentina hot sauce but how are you
around spicy food in general i'm okay
with hot food i'm mexican
a mexican
i i've been on a break from alcohol and
hot food
for about three months
so let's see if my tongue has forgotten
you know what it's like and you know how
to endure the hotness it will do the
test
[Music]
hmm
oh it's good
[Music]
it's very good
[Music]
i'm a little bit nervous because i was
under the impression like the first one
it's not hot at all yeah
but a little bit of a kick a little bit
it's hot
it's hot i i'm terrified how it's going
to get but it's really good yeah and
you're going back in you're going back
in
since we've touched on you play ajak and
eternals the spiritual leader of an
immortal team of superheroes and
recently director chloe zhao told a
story about you waiting out a production
delay lost in your headphones listening
to the atmospheric nils from song says
and it made me curious what role if any
does music play in helping you to get
into a character like ajax
like every character
it's so important in my life
and
it's it makes my job really fun because
i do my own
score for the character
and it keeps me staying the vibe and it
really puts you in your own little micro
universe where anything can happen and
everything it's enhanced like the trees
the lights everything is so much more
interesting with music so i always use
it
[Music]
it's not bad it's not too sweet
so there's an iconic instagram photo
that you have you're holding a stack of
tacos and it's captioned the passion
that never left me as someone who's
lived and traveled the world is there a
place outside of mexico that you think
does tacos best you know i live in
london now there is a place i go with my
daughter valentina who loves it and it's
just called taqueria
i mean not very original the name
but uh we love it they make good tacos
and and and i have a place called
mestizo in london they sell the taco
soup but you can buy all the mexican
ingredients everything that you need you
can buy there to make the food at home
so the best tacos
[Music]
outside of mexico
any one of my houses
[Music]
i like it but maybe a little bit too
salty
well if someone says it then it's the
truth
so what do you remember about the
mechanics of shooting that trolley car
crash scene in frida for my money one of
the best movie scenes oh that's a good
one
it was very complicated
it's actually one of the few times that
there was a lot of dialogue about it and
should we try this should we try that
because julie tamer is amazing she knows
exactly what she wants she's very
technical she's very visual she's very
good
i love it because she said she painted
her reality but her reality was so
poetic in so many ways because that's
the way she chose to see it and i think
this is the perfect scene that says a
lot about her spirit and the way she saw
things where it's one of the most tragic
moments of her life and yet it was so
beautiful you know and it did happen
that there was a painter in the trolley
that had a gold powder and so there was
the blood there was there was a blob
there was the blood but there was the
gold and it's just uh there was
something magical
about this really painful moment in her
life that marked her forever and then in
2014 you produced an animated film the
prophet based on cleo gabron's classic
book yes yes what's special about that
project that makes it one of the few
movies that you've done that you'd like
to rewatch
oh my god i had a sentimental attachment
to the book because of my grandfather
who was lebanese and who kept the book
by his bed
as i grew older i read that book many
different times and i keep seeing it in
a different way and in a way every time
i find something new to learn from it i
feel it's like my grandfather
that even though he's not here with me
he's still teaching me about life
through this amazing poet
[Music]
i lost calientes the hot ones very
appropriate for the show
[Music]
is that a good is that a good mmm oh
yeah
we'll take that
so in addition to your more than 80
acting credits you've also left your
mark behind the camera founding your
production company ventanarosa in 1999
and i've heard you say some incisive
things about the discouraging and
heartbreaking process of shopping
scripts when you hear about a script
that's locked away in a drawer in a
production studio somewhere how did it
get there and what's keeping that movie
from getting made a lot of times is
money
you have a great concept that everybody
likes
but you have to have writers writing it
and sometimes
it's
the writers are not doing exactly what
the director or the studio what's hoping
for but you have to pay them
so here comes another writer
sometimes you have to buy the bio the
rights of the book
and then
you don't have them after a certain time
so you have to pay again and a lot of
the times you just get like a big bill
and the movie has not started
and it just becomes really hard to make
it and it's sad because things are
changing now but in the past if you had
a script that was a great script about a
minority it wouldn't get made
because
there was not enough minorities that
could open a film
according to the studios you know not
big enough the name and if the script is
expensive
you have to have one of the ali's which
is a very limited number of actors and
usually they're not minorities so things
are beginning to change but there were a
lot of great stories
that because they were not
easy to cast just because the big stars
were not of that type of diversity died
hopefully they'll come back now
it's spicy yeah a little bit of a step
up
like four steps up
yeah
but it's good but you know what i'm
impressed
i'll take that i'll take the eyes are
watering
a little bit right that's your tail
oh i like this but you're not you're not
pink on the face yet not yet not yet
it'll get there i think i'm i'm hoping
cause you know what i had a theory
i was wondering if you give me this and
then you just have a little bit of
barbecue sauce right you know in all of
you so i was going to say
well let's let's um exchange the wing
maybe we do that for the next one all
right fine i'm down with that i'm i'm
a-okay with that i'm going to switch
suspicious
sure sure i am i'm totally fine
i am a chicken wing talk show host of
dignity you are you actually are yeah
all right sama we have recurring segment
on our show called explain that graham
we're doing a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so we'll put the
picture up on the monitor and given your
love of animals it's an all wildlife
theme for salma hayek do you have any uh
truffle hunting 101 tips that you picked
up on this afternoon that you spent with
zara and mala i'll tell you a funny
story about it so
we went to look for the truffles and
the guide was a fan
and he said to me look
i love you too much i cannot lie to you
okay
the truth is
it's we don't know if we're going to
find truffles or not and we don't want
to
disappoint the tourists
so
we hide them sometimes
but
you
i was in love with the dogs but what
we're gonna do now is gonna do we're
gonna do it differently
one of you goes and hides them
and we're gonna wait here and then i'm
gonna show you how the dogs find it
but my girls were naughty i mean they
hit those things
on the trees under the water i mean they
really were so mean to the dogs and we
couldn't find them forever but the dogs
found them they finally found them i
love truffles i have to admit they're
the best all right one more for you
you're the first person i've ever
interviewed with an owl as a pet can you
give me a pro and a con of having an owl
as a pet
if it's a hot night you can sleep with
it and they're like flying all night you
know and you can feel the air as they
fly by
she's just lovely
funny
temperamental
you know she can be moody and i love
that about her too
her eyes are hypnotic and they really
calm me down what i don't like
they have to eat the rats
that's what i feed them and a couple of
times she's landed on my head with the
rat and that just it's not a good
sensation
that's just not cool
lechuga that's lettuce
mr lettuce
[Music]
i like this one
it has a little bit of cinnamon in it oh
yeah can you taste it
good yeah this is different
it's very nice it's sauce it's hot but
it's very nice
i'm i'm into it
so there's a quote of yours i thought
was really interesting where you said
producing is hell writing is frustrating
acting is really satisfying directing is
heaven and in journalism writers will
oftentimes become editors because it's a
clearer career path to more stability
and money but that's not necessarily the
case for a-list actors becoming
directors how do you explain the draw
i think for me like
what my draw would be is that sometimes
you have a story to tell
and i don't want the limitation of my
body
and who i am to just tell one character
of someone else's story but to tell the
perspective of a story that you have a
special perspective on it on something
like if your brain is wired in a way
that the way you can tell it is not so
much with words
but with moods
and the little moments the details
you want to feel it you know you want to
feel the light you want to be able to
put the music into it and work with the
actors and
you know like for maybe you
are wiring that way or have that desire
to direct because i can see you pay a
lot of attention to detail
and uh
but you would have wanted to do it even
if you had done a different career i
think it's a way of being wiring
having that
perspective and an interesting visual
way to do it like for example
i'm very highly dyslexic so my brain
instead of reading words to seize images
and that's like a good
thing if you wanted to be a director
of fire
okay whatever that means
bigger kick though but you're doing good
i like this one wow this one would taste
good do you mind if i put some lemon in
it go ahead go for it that's why that's
why it's real salty too there we go mmm
i like this one a lot i like this
you have to remember that in mexico
[Music]
you grow up with candy
like when you're a kid
must be like
as hot as number three
it's sweet but it's full of chili
there's a lot of spicy candy that
children do eat
so you get used to it there we go
i like it
learning all sorts of things today
one of your passions that i know that
you pursue in your downtime is diving
which you've been doing since you were
10 years old diving besides that time
that you had to be transported to a
decompression chamber for eight hours
afterwards
deep voyage
have you ever had a harrowing encounter
with a sea creature or anything i've had
so many encounters with sea creatures
and they come i have a good vibe i have
a good good vibe yeah
i had an octopus one time
explore me
was very interesting
i stay very still
but it goes dark but at the beginning
there was some light going in there and
just to see the
their tentacles attached to the thing
you have to hold on to the respirator
because they can pull it out
and he was moving the mask and going
around i still very calm very still
and he explored me and left i was
strange
just because their texture and
everything about them is so interesting
here's me breaking down the fourth wall
here and just being your friend you're
crushing it you're doing great but this
is gonna kill me right right
[Laughter]
as long as it doesn't give me diarrhea
no problem i have a movie to promote
if it does i'm gonna send you to the
mexican mafia oh okay all right all
right well i'm keeping my fingers
this is very hot i'm not good
oh my god
i am playing an eternal but my tongue is
still human
what do you remember about i mean it's a
it's a tricky bastard because like even
at the beginning it's not as hot and as
time goes by it grows and it grows and
it grows yeah it doesn't seem to stop or
slow down
what do you remember about eating the
heart of a sea dragon in your film tale
of tales was it that more or less
disgusting than the wing we just ate
[Music]
you didn't hurt that one
it was disgusting
oh my tongue is on it's hurting
oh
too much pain for very little pleasure
oh my god that should be the tagline
[Music]
i'm going back to the to the ones at the
beginning yeah it's like cleansing
my my doritos with
[Music]
[Music]
it's terrible i'm not answering any more
questions to you
my tongue hurts
we'll slow it down we'll slow it down
my question was
[Music]
it's a disgusting question sure but
it's not
really really like hot with something
have you ever had somebody who
their nose started to run in the middle
of the show yeah yeah i've seen runny
noses and i was afraid of it but i think
i'm doing okay you're doing great you're
doing great i've seen it all over here
i've seen it all from the side of the
table
oh
god
number
what makes the the small japanese
restaurant oh yeah in boston uh one of
the most inspiring places that you've
ever eaten
creativity there we go
they are so original the taste is just
so good and the fish is so good but they
have some
really special dishes that i love
oh my god it's still burning
do you want to slow down do you want to
move on to the next one
i want this taste to get out of my mouth
right right right
i'm about to start crying
let's take this is gonna be even harder
i guess there's only one way to find out
there's only one way to find out
[Music]
it's very very hot
at least it tastes good
the other one is just like
an attack to the tongue you know and and
you don't even get to feel any flavor
just paint
no no no no no
like a bad lover
it's the first time i've heard the sauce
i've heard this sauce described so many
ways first time i've ever heard it
described that way
[Laughter]
i'm not good but i like the other one
the other one is hot
but it's a different kind of hut
it's it's not like i'm gonna make a
sauce that people want to make some
jokes to their friends right you know
prank sauce prank sauce or to attack or
just to say oh i am macho macho i can
eat these sauce no this one it's like
and what the one i just tried it's
called what the bomb this one is like
your dog is about to melt right yeah and
that's not a good thing
oh okay earlier this year you starred in
bliss which is a sci-fi movie that
wrestles with the idea of artificially
simulated worlds and then one of frida
kahlo's most famous paintings the two
fritas has some like parallel universe
qualities to it do you think frito would
have embraced a connection between art
and string theory she would have loved
it
it's part of what you can see in her art
it's it's very interesting
it's a very interesting question
she was able to paint in one painting
many aspects of her reality
that maybe for nobody else saw the
reality like that
but she felt it very real
so i think i i think she would have been
fascinated
with string theory and different
dimensions
different possibilities of existing at
the same time
and that's
the worst one
[Music]
it's an insult to the tongue
the way you do it is you don't want to
dab it on the wing right rub it next to
it yeah you know you'd think at this
point
i figured that out but uh you know
a million times
dump the sauce all over the uh all over
the wing but you're right that's the
smart way to do it
because you never know
what it's going to be like
especially when they're thick
sometimes too much just comes out that's
someone who's been around hot sauce a
lot before all right salma hayek at long
lasting i'm finishing this one
[Music]
now i'm going back into
[Music]
you know what
i am a dog adopting you
whoa as a mexican even if you're not
[Laughter]
you are a honorary mexican from today on
you can really handle your chilis such a
compliment coming from you salma hayek
and you know what at long last we've
conquered the wings of death and just
one more annoyingly drawn out question
before we roll credits
you know your origin story of leaving
soap operas in mexico to take a chance
in hollywood it's well known but one
thing that i found interesting was a
revelation that you had when you said my
passion was not acting it was movies can
you unpackage what you meant by that
while your brain and tongue slow roast
in hot sauce
because you know if you ask me
who did you want to be like like what
was your favorite actor that you wanted
to be like who was your icon i didn't
have one
i just want to be part of the films i
just wanted to be in the films
and uh when they asked me what was the
movie that made you want to be an
actress
i would say willy wonka and the
chocolate factory because when i was a
little girl i was watching it and i
thought it was amazing i said
wait a minute wow
there is a universe where everything is
possible
and you can live in another era in the
past or in the future
and you know you can have a river made
out of chocolate everything is possible
and that's films
everything is possible to talking about
realities and string theory back to that
and so i just want to be a part of that
and it's been so much fun
beautifully said glamorously crushing
the wings of death today and look at you
salma hayek coming into hot ones taking
down the wings of death living to tell
the tale and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet i wish my
husband was here so i could kiss him
and then he's he'll be he's be on fire
wouldn't even know why
but in the meantime somehow this camera
this camera or this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
i have
a movie coming out called eternals
with a bunch of amazing people and the
best director in the world
i'm very proud to be part of this
project you have to come and see it and
then i have a small part but really fun
in another movie later on this year with
lady gaga called house of gucci so i was
going to be a good ridley scott director
so very
very excited i got to work with such
good directors come and check them out
[Applause]
you did it
great job
i had a lovely time
but also the questions were very smart
oh thank you i appreciate that
how many do you do believe it or not
we've done that i think i've done this
like 230 times
this is the you're in the 16th season
but you do it once a week yeah so we do
like um like 36 episodes a year so like
uh 12 episodes seasons no because the
amount of research is uh
a lot of work yeah yeah but you know
what uh i love it i love doing that i i
love watching your movies and kind of
like diving into your life no you can't
tell that you like movies a lot
you're
but sometimes it's not just movies that
you have to yeah but that's i like the
variation though like i kind of like
walking around somebody else's shoes
kind of like seeing what it's like
experiencing their art listening their
music reading their books watching their
movies whatever and then sitting down
with them and then just seeing if you
could execute against that but that's my
favorite part of my job and who's the
worst one you've ever interviewed
after the camera
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement hungry for more a
brand new documentary series from first
we feast is now live on the channel you
know this black box it's great for
grilling celebrities over scorching hot
chicken wings from week to week but
outside of these walls is a whole new
vanguard of chefs restaurant tours and
do-it-yourself food hustlers who are
taking comfort food to their communities
and beyond from a mom and pop taco shop
that my boy jj reddick calls the best in
the country to a bronx native taking the
iconic new york chop cheese sandwich to
the streets
without further ado you know the drill
colin
roll the tape
when i had my first chopped cheese i
thought this is amazing it's a sandwich
that you gotta be from new york to be
familiar with we chose to go the
plant-based route
when we were gonna open this space no
one understood what we were trying to
build my identity has always been a
rural follower and now with edith i feel
like we're breaking every rule if we're
gonna make it like we have to be
adaptable
food for me has always been sort of like
a pursuit announcement as a young player
my way to explore a city was to explore
the restaurant
you want to make it in the world you got
to start from your corner i'm just happy
to showcase my food to more people you
know identify all the beauty that's
within the neighborhood and bring it out
to the world
[Music]
[Applause]
you